hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer
neuen episode the german heute aus
chicago
wenn man darüber redet wohin man fährt
dann kann man im deutschen drei
verschiedene positionen benutzen
ich fliege nach berlin ich fliege in die
schweiz oder ich gehe zur schule
ich gehe zum yoga im englischen
übersetzt man alles mit two im deutschen
hat man drei verschiedene positionen und
wir erklären euch heute wann man welche
position benutzt los geht's benutzt man
immer dann wenn man in einen
geschlossenen oder begrenzten raum geht
ich gehe in das haus ich gehe in das
gebäude
man kann sich vorstellen beide haben
einen dach aber auch etwas was offen ist
aber eine art grenze hat kann mit ihnen
benutzt werden zum beispiel ich gehe in
den park also in benutzt man immer dann
wenn es ein geschlossener oder
begrenzter raum ist zu benutzt man immer
dann wenn man zu einer person einer
veranstaltung oder einer institution
geht zum beispiel ich fahre zu oma ich
gehe zum konzert oder ich gehe zur
schule
ich gehe zum yoga nach benutzt man für
länder städte und richtungen
ich fahre nach england ich fahre nach
berlin ich fahre nach norden
es gibt zwei ausnahmen ich sage ich
fahre nach hause
das ist ein fester ausdruck und ich kann
auch manchmal in mit ländern benutzen
und zwar immer dann wenn ein land einen
artikel hat ich sage also ich fliege in
die usa
ich fahre in den irak ich fahre in den
jemen
also immer wenn ein land einen artikel
hat benutzt man nicht nach das ist eine
ausnahme
wenn ihr wissen wollt welche
länder im deutschen einen artikel haben
dann könnt ihr dieses video schauen dass
wir schon einmal dazu gemacht haben
besonders ist auch dass man mit manchen
orten zwei präpositionen benutzen kann
ich kann in die schule gehen denn ist es
ein geschlossenes gebäude
aber ich kann auch zur schule gehen denn
es ist auch eine institution und jetzt
zeigen wir euch eine kleine geschichte
damit ihr ein bisschen mehr übung
bekommt haben wir ein video darüber
gedreht wie wir von berlin nach chicago
gereist sind und da gab es auch einige
turbulenzen und damit könnt ihr ein
bisschen üben wann man welche positionen
benutzt hier ist die geschichte heute
reisen wir in die usa es ist elf uhr
morgens und wir fahren zum flughafen
als erstes gehen wir zur u bahn
mit dem aufzug fahren wir zum bahnsteig
mit der u bahn fahren wir nach süden im
süden von berlin liegt der flughafen
berlin-schönefeld janus geht in das
flughafengebäude
wir fliegen nicht nach manchester nicht
nach brüssel
wir fliegen nach reykjavik wir gehen zum
check-in-schalter dann gehen wir zu
unserem geld
als erstes liegen wir nach island dort
wollen wir umsteigen in ein flugzeug
nach chicago
wir gehen zum gate doch dann lief
plötzlich alles anders als geplant am
gate habe ich gemerkt dass ich meinen
pass nicht mehr hatte ich habe meinen
pass verloren und ich hatte ihn noch am
flughafen in berlin aber nicht mehr ins
land
natürlich haben wir sofort panik gehabt
wir haben alle unsere klamotten
durchwühlt und gesucht und ihn nicht
gefunden
sie hat dann beim flughafen in berlin
angerufen und die polizei dort hatte
meinen pass dann mussten wir plötzlich
alles um planen wenn saß schon im
flugzeug nach chicago aber wir konnten
nicht mit wir haben ben angerufen und
haben gesagt du musst leider ohne uns
die easy german tour beginnen und dann
haben wir einen neuen plan gemacht und
den seht ihr jetzt am nächsten tag
fliege ich um sechs uhr morgens zurück
nach berlin
in berlin habe ich 20 minuten zeit
dann fliegt das flugzeug zurück
eine frau vom flughafen hilft mehr
zusammen rennen wir so schnell wie
möglich zur polizei diese frau ist
unglaublich sie hat alles für mich
vorbereitet
wir holen meinen pass ab und rennen
zurück zum sicherheitscheck dann renne
ich zurück zum flugzeug nach reykjavik
verrückt ich bin in vier stunden von
island nach deutschland geflogen und
dann direkt wieder vier stunden von
deutschland nach russland zurück flog am
flughafen in reykjavik treffe ich ja nun
schon wieder zusammen gehen wir zu
unserem geld endlich sitzen wir im
flugzeug nach chicago
sieben stunden später landen wir in
chicago als erstes gehen wir zum
immigrations schalter dann gehen wir zum
flughafenbahnhof
dies geht nach rechts aber er will
eigentlich nach links gehen mit dem zug
wollen wir in die stadt fahren von der
bahnstation gehen wir direkt zu unserer
wohnung kam nach 40 stunden reise sind
wir endlich in chicago angekommen
hier treffen wir endlich benno wenn ihr
diese präpositionen jetzt selber üben
möchte dann werdet einfach ein patriot
von easy german als patron erhaltet ihr
jede woche interaktive übungen und zu
diesem thema haben wir extra ein eigenes
übungsplatz für euch vorbereitet
wir sind mittlerweile übrigens auf dem
weg nach ohio und wenn ihr sehen wollt
wie unsere easy german tour weiter geht
dann folgt uns einfach auf patchen und
auch auf instagram die links sind hier
und hier unten klickt mal drauf wir
freuen uns auf euch bis nächste woche